انتشر في الساعات الماضيه مقطع فيديو
لوالده اللاعب الشهير جرار مع شاكيرا
بجانبهما ايضا والمقطع حصد ملايين
المشاهدات نتابعه
الفيديو الذي عرضناه صوره احد المره في
مكان عام ويظهر فيه نقاش محتدم بين شاكيرا
ووالده ويبدو ان الام لم تكن راضيه عن
كلام شاكيرا وحاولت اسكاتها ووضعت يدها
على فمها حتى لكن شاكيرا بقيت تتكلم لتقوم
والده بالاشاره بسبابتها على فمها لتسقط
شاكيرا كل هذا فيما بيكي يقف بينهما
متفرجا الفيديو تم تداوله بشكل كبير وضم
كثيرون انه جديد الحقيقه انه قديم من وقت
علاقه الثنائي وسبب تداوله اليوم من جديد
غير معلوم لكن عموما الحديث عن العلاقه
السيئه بين شاكيرا ووالده ليست جديده
فالاخبار عن العلاقه السيئه التي جمعت
السيده تان لم تتوقف وكان دائما عنوانها
انها ولن تحب شاكيرا ولم تكن داعمه لعلاقه
الثنائي وكانت تتهم ماء دائما بانشغالها
بعملها واهمالها وطفليهما
تم تداول اخبار عن مصادر اعلاميه ان والده
بيكي كانت على علم بعلاقته الجديده ولكنها
لم تخبر شاكيرا ومن ثم شاهدنا والده ووالد
بيكي علنا بصحبه ابنهما وحبيبته الجديده
فيما يشير لرضاهما عن العلاقه التوتر بين
شاكيرا ووالدتك هذا كان بلغ اوجه بعض
انفصال الثنائي فراينا اخبار مدعومه بصور
ومقاطع لبناء شاكيرا جدارا فاصلا بين
منزلها في برشلونه ومنزل والده بيكا هذا
كمان سبق ذلك وضع شاكيرا لدميه ساحره على
شرفتها المطله على منزل والده بيكيه وقامت
بتشغيل اغنيتها على صوت مرتفع ومسموع
نتحدث هنا عن الاغنيه التي طرحتها شاكيرا
من شهرين وشغلت العالم وحققت نجاحا كبيرا
وحطمت ارقاما قياسيه وفيها تهاجم شاكيرا
بيكي وحبيبته الجديده بشكل غير مباشر
[موسيقى]